hey this is big Paul Ryan Speaker of the
House Republican has admitted that
Donald Trump helped write that terrible
health care bill the American health
care act let me lay it out for you okay
so up to this point Donald Trump has
taken more or less of a wait-and-see
approach towards the Republican health
care plan the aah a see whether or not
it passes see whether or not it does
well if it passes before he really takes
a strong position on it and Trump
initially sort of came out in support of
the bill because it was a replacement to
Obamacare which he promised to do
hundreds of times during the campaign
but now that the bill isn't doing so
well Trump doesn't seem nearly as eager
to have people call it Trump care and
Trump said he'd campaign for the bill
but if it ended up failing he would just
end up blaming Democrats for the failure
of Obamacare and people in Trump's camp
are now blaming Paul Ryan for the lack
of enthusiasm behind the bill we've
heard from anonymous White House staff
and and congressional Republicans who
are loyal to Trump accusing Paul Ryan of
having misled Trump into thinking the
bill was going to be more popular an
anonymous source who's close to Trump
said to Breitbart quote if Paul Ryan
doesn't get his act together soon the
president will have no choice but to
step in and fix this on his own he's the
best negotiator on the planet and if
this were his bill not Ryan's it would
not be this much of a mess sounds like
something John Miller would say of
course John Miller an alias for Donald
Trump that we found out he would
sometimes use when speaking to the media
and on Tuesday night Breitbart which has
sort of become the unofficial propaganda
arm of the White House released leaked
audio of Paul Ryan bad-mouthing Trump
back in October saying that Ryan's
betrayal of Trump during the election
should be a focal point in health care
negotiations blah blah blah let's take a
listen to that for a second as for
myself as your Speaker I am NOT going to
defend Donald Trump not now not in the
future as you probably heard I just
invited him my first congressional
district GOP event this weekend a thing
I do every year and I'm not going to be
campaigning with him over the next
thirty days so most recently the latest
is that Paul Ryan is now trying to throw
Trump under the under the bus by
revealing that Trump actually did help
right right this bill he said to CNBC
yesterday quote obviously the major
components are staying intact because
this is something we wrote with
President Trump so Paul Ryan for the
first time is referring to Trump as one
of the writers of this bill this has
happened multiple times since this audio
was released so let's big picture it
Republican health care plan is a total
disaster it's looking more and more
every day like it's gonna have trouble
getting through the House and Senate and
therefore Republicans now are just
standing around blaming each other which
is the height of incompetence what I
really get angry about here Pat is when
I think about the fact that citizens
voted for these people their taxes pay
for their salaries and what they're
doing is hanging around blaming each
other for bills that would be terrible
for their constituents if they even
passed this is something that should
every single voter regardless of party
affiliation I honestly take Trump side
over Ryan's here because I have a really
tough time believing that truth about
anything co-authored this bill
especially because he only found out a
few weeks ago that the topic of health
care is complicated yeah I can't imagine
him writing any of this I assume what
Ryan means is not that Trump literally
was there writing but that he had he
exerted influence in terms of what
wouldn't wouldn't be in the bill
conceptually that's what I assume it
means to say Trump co-wrote it I agree
with you the idea that Trump's writing
anything is very hard to believe it's
also surprising that he's not willing to
put his own name on the bill Donald
Trump that is because he's put his name
on a fraudulent University Ponzi scheme
and he's got his name on vodka even
though he doesn't drink
it's odd yeah it's odd that this now is
too far for Trump to put his name on
something he doesn't understand or was
directly involved in and because of that
we can't even really speculate what it
is that Trump is trying to accomplish or
what he wants to have happen with health
care because he probably really has no
actual ideas and remember a ton of
trumps campaign promises about health
care were the antithesis of this new
bill every
but he's going to be covered if you
can't afford it the government's going
to pay for it it's gonna be affordable
for everybody what Trump does seem smart
enough to realize is that things are
starting to go south with the American
Health Care Act and it could be soon
time to be abandoning a sinking ship CNN
reported that during a meeting between
Senate leadership and White House staff
quote a senior Republican aide to a
senator in the room said that the White
House is definitely looking at pretty
big changes to the Ryan bill the Ryan
bill I mean it's brilliant right
especially if it's true that Trump
helped write it hey I'm Donald this is
my plan no no no I'm Paul Ryan and this
has been my plan for years plan goes
south
Trump hey this is the Paul Ryan plan we
don't know anything about this thing
Paul Ryan Trump co-authored this thing
and some Trump advisors are beginning to
say that they acknowledge the bill
doesn't have enough votes and they need
to start maybe fresh this is naturally
what's going to happen when you have a
health care bill that half of people
think is too conservative half of people
think it is too liberal and the
president is just a clueless opportunist
who will sign his name to anything he
thinks will help him in popularity but
doesn't really get it obviously this is
what's going to happen this really was
Ryan's creation and if he's going to
lose his own party on this especially in
the Senate they can only afford to lose
two votes on this bill so if it
continues to go any further you're going
to see people people trying to make Paul
Ryan own it instead of Trump unless it
happens and succeeds in which case Trump
will take credit for it there's there's
no doubt about that he as soon as this
goes even mildly okay this is Trump's
plan and he's going to tout this as an
accomplishment